hello everyone and welcome to the Jax uh
diffuse diffusers uh Sprint Kick coffee
kickoff event uh we will have like great
talks today about diffusion models uh
what are the state of what's going on
with state of the art we will have an
introduction to diffusers and more
and without further Ado I will take our
first Speaker Emil Emil is working in
Google
would you like to introduce yourself
yeah sure so uh hi I'm Emil I recently
finished my my PhD and I've been working
on generative models throughout my PhD
first normalizing flows and now now the
fusion models
awesome
well I will just uh
have your screen here and I will leave
you with your awesome talk
thank you so much
yeah so thank you for joining thank you
for listening uh today I'll be talking
about some recent work we did uh simple
diffusion and this was work together
with Jonathan hake and Tim salimons
and the outside of this this project was
really to make diffusion work well for
high resolution images
um while keeping the model as simple as
possible and so what we will see is that
compared to the original model that
Jonathan ho and LJ introduced
a really not so many different changes
are needed it's kind of kind of simple
in a sense
um
but these changes changes are really
important because before this diffusion
didn't really work on high resolution
images directly
um
so the goal is to generate images for
now
at a high resolution
natively directly
in pixel space
and kind of the motivation for a model
like this is that it's super simple
right you just have one model you don't
have we'll get into that later but you
can have like latent models or super
resolution models
this model just just generates an image
in the resolution that you wanted to
um and it might even be faster in
certain cases
we can discuss that also a little bit
later
um
so when we started this project
people were mainly doing two things to
achieve
um
high quality results
and one way was doing Cascades
so you would start out with a small
model on a base resolution say 32
sometimes starting at 64. and then you
would do these Cascades these super
resolution diffusion models that were
conditioned on the previous smaller
resolution image
um
you could kind of up sample to the to
the resolution that you needed and in
this way the the work is a little bit
divided between the different
resolutions so the first model doesn't
have to do everything it can do like a
small part and then the second model
does some more and then the third model
he does like the final details
and another one that people are I guess
familiar with is the is the stable
diffusion approach uh which is
diffusional latent spaces
um and this is nice right to to be able
to operate on a latent space it means
that the variables to cooperate on are
much smaller so it's usually simpler to
to handle that in a computer
but it also brings complications right
because you have now two models
and you need to train them separately
you have an auto encoder and you have a
diffusion model you're not really sure
how these interact
and if you try this out on new data it
might work miraculously or might feel
and you you don't really know why and
you don't have a good way to train these
things end to end
um so we can ask ourselves why why
didn't we just do diffusion models on
high resolution images
and it turns out that the basic problem
is we weren't adding enough noise
and it's it's very simple to just show
this
um here on this slide on the on the top
row
um is like a typical schedule that that
people have used for diffusion the
cosine schedule it's it's for the alpha
parameter in a variance preserving
diffusion model
and this is a linear over time starting
at T equals zero to T equals one
and this is showing the different noise
levels in between
and now
the diffusion process is is what's going
from left to right so it's destroying
the data it's it's uh it's giving a
statistical distribution uh statistical
description of how to destroy data
and the general theft process is
learning the reverse so it's going from
right to left
another problem here is that in very
small steps like the last one so going
from the final noise to the right to the
left one
uh a lot has to be generated in like
this small amount of time
because if we if we squint our eyes a
little bit we can see kind of the shape
already we can see it's a bird so the
generator models have degenerative model
has made a lot of decisions already on
what this image should look like
and this is not really desires we want
to spread out a lot of these choices
over more time because it means they're
doing training for more or more sample
efficient we're kind of defining the
work over time uh equally
um and also during sampling it means
that
um
we allow the model for more time to take
these small steps
um and it turns out there's a there's a
very simple way to correct this noise
schedule
and this correction is shown on the
bottom and there you can see that the
the the destruction is far more
um far more gradual in some sense so uh
in the in the right the rightmost images
noise but if we go one to the left
it's kind of you see some shapes but you
cannot really see it's a it's a bird and
then the middle one maybe but maybe only
if I if I told you that's what you
should be looking for
um
so the point is that the model now has a
lot more time
to generate the different concepts in
this image
um
and now now the question is okay what is
this uh modification to the schedule
that you have to do and for this it's
very helpful to look in the log as in
our space of the noise schedule
and the log SNR is a is a way to
field the alpha and sigma parameters of
a diffusion model
it's it is
um so the signal to noise ratio is Alpha
divided by Sigma both squared
and then the log SNR is the is the log
of that value and what makes this so
nice is that there are doubles of paper
vdm which showed that this this ratio is
basically the only thing that matters
and like whether your processes frames
preserving or variance exploding you can
repair
re-parametrize them as each other it
doesn't really matter the only thing
that matters is the ratio between Alpha
and sigma
um
and so the the modification that we make
um is a shift
and it's it's shown here that's kind of
a shift with respect to a reference
resolution resolution where we think
that our schedule would work well
and the resolution at which we operate
um and so here in this example we are
generating an image of a resolution of
but we're shifting that schedule as if
we're generating it as a resolution of
64. so what that literally means is that
if we use this schedule
we apply it to our 128 image
and we would down sample it with with
average pooling we would get exactly uh
the cosine schedule there
um
and here on the bottom right I've shown
some results showing that this is really
an important thing to do so just by
doing the shift you can get fids for
resolution 128 a little bit lower
but if you look at a resolution of 256
which is a lot higher of course
then this really starts to become
important I think this is also this
explains why you were seeing such large
gaps in the FID scores of
models in literature it's just that
[Music]
um
like when going to these higher
resolutions it's it's super difficult if
the model only has this very small
amount of time to generate the whole
image
and
we really saw that for high resolutions
uh diffusion models performed very poor
unless you were doing one of these
tricks right so super resolution or or
latent diffusion but this really in some
sense
solves this problem and
this reference resolution is just
something that we that we picked that
seems logical uh so in these imagenet
experiments uh 32 or 64 kind of made
sense
um but suppose you you have a problem
where you're only generating texture
right for texture the global structure
is not important at all so you might not
want to shift your schedule so it can
really depend on the on the type of data
that you want to generate how you want
to modify your schedule
another important thing to to make this
uh computationally feasible is to do
patching
um so
the problem is that
no matter how you want to kind of turn
it around if you start doing
convolutional layers on very high
uh resolution feature Maps so like two
five six and 128 are pretty high already
it's just going to become super
expensive so we have some like back of
back of the envelope calculations in the
paper
um
it's kind of tricky because even if you
keep the flops constant your memory will
still increase linearly
um and it's just it's just not worth it
so one of the things we we realize is
that we can patch so it just means like
shuffling the pixels from the spatial
Dimensions to the channel dimensions
um and that works really well and a
slight modification on top of that is to
do that with DVD transform discrete
wavelet transforms
and that's like in our experience a
little bit more stable
Works a little bit better
[Music]
um
but the patching is really patching is
really something that you that you kind
of always want to do at these high
resolution
um
uh images and it's it's almost
unbelievable we we thought that patching
would give us a penalty but it would be
worth it in terms of uh compute time
the funny thing is it also improves
um also improves the performance of the
networks and and we're not really sure
why this is you might have to do
something but stability like having a
very deep unit might
might be difficult to get stable uh deep
in terms of different levels
but if you look at the the
right here you can see that even though
our train step time increase by by 50
percent are FID scores were actually
better
so patching is just at these high
resolutions it's kind of a free game
from both
uh performance and and step time
and then the the
one other thing that we did was we we
wanted to scale this up basically so we
wanted to increase the
increase the size of these Networks
and with with these units there are so
many parameters right so it's like how
many levels do you have where where do
you do the self-attention
um all these different choices that you
can make
and there's like this middle block
that's weird and there's all this
concatenation and it's kind of so it's
all kind of tricky to to to get working
and to know like what are the trade-offs
um
and we we want to scale in a way that we
knew performance would get better it it
didn't necessarily need to be like it
didn't need to be the most optimal way
to scale the model
but it needed to be reasonable
so we thought that it made sense to
scale the aspect of the model that has
self-attention
because the fusion models without
self-attention They Don't Really
generate like nice coherent images uh
self-attention is a really important
component
and we realized that
um like if you're doing a residual block
and then self-attention it's very close
already to doing an MLP block and
self-attention it's basically replacing
the convolutional layers with with uh
one by one columns or dense layers
um so that's exactly what we did so we
we replaced these rest Blocks made
things a little bit simpler
um and that's what you see here so on
the top you would have a typical
uh unit architecture
um so it would have some uh like
embedding and then some rest blocks
average pooling rest blocks and then
especially this middle part is a little
bit messy so you have like rest blocks
then one middle rest block and then then
the whole thing back up again
um and in this new architecture we we
introduced
um
we we basically took the same structure
but in the middle we just put a big
Transformer and a Transformer is just
MLP blocks with self-attention so we
would do the the rest blocks average
pooling to the level down not a rest
block uh another couple of rest blocks
average pulling down and then just a
Transformer
we didn't even use
um like the concatenation or other types
of skip connections there it was just
one residual Transformer and and that
works super well
so and and one of the things that
produced us early that this should be
possible is that we were only scaling in
the units the 16 by 16 resolution
uh so we felt that that would be a good
resolution also to uh to scale this
you've hit on
um
yeah and and that works well and it also
has like slightly better uh utilization
in the matrix multiplication units so
it's kind of a nice a simple
architecture to to work with
and then
one one final thing it's kind of it's
almost silly to talk about it but it is
really important it's where you add
dropouts for a data set like imagenet so
data set like imagenet is large uh like
the one million image that that people
use for this stuff
um
but it's it's not large enough right so
the model C the data set uh numerous
times
and they really start to overfit all
this data
and if you don't use dropouts uh your
performance is very bad so I think we
have the number here so for this
internet 128 experiments is like 3.7
uh without Dropbox
and then
one of the things that like Dropout of
all the hyper parameter choices that you
would have in a unit Dropout will be
kind of a global parameter that you
would set so you would set dropouts on
on all rest blocks
um
so you would you would set it everywhere
and here we can see that that would give
a resolution of 3.2 sorry an FID score
3.2
um so improving a little bit from 3.7 to
um
yeah but not but not really a lot
um and it turns out that on that high
resolution you should really not be
adding Dropout and it's kind of the only
resolution where you cannot add it so we
did an experiment where we said okay
we're gonna add dropouts from and below
this level so from and Below 128 is all
the levels
1064 and down and 32 and down and 16 and
down and all the other ones kind of
performed similar but the one where we
add a drop out on this highest these
high resolution highest resolution
feature Maps so that the feature maps
for your for your input and output space
is
um yeah that that's really problematic
so
um yeah this this is kind of
a very easy thing to do it's like to add
in dropouts at a particular place
and not adding it in another particular
place but it is really important if
you're doing something like imagenet
you're seeing your data a couple of
times
um
yeah that this this is really important
if you if you train on larger scale data
sets like texture image data sets uh
this is much less important uh
took F5
and then then the data set is so large
that it doesn't really matter
um yeah one of the um one of the other
improvements
um is the the multi-skill laws
it's kind of
uh it's kind of annoying in a sense that
we still have to do this and it might
allude to
uh
we we may have not solved this problem
completely uh if this is still needed uh
because what we found is for the really
high resolution so for um two five six
and five twelve and we we get some
preliminary events on
on 1024 also
um the model still has difficulty uh
fitting the the data
and higher higher the resolution the
more it has difficulty
and
like one of the ways we kind of
circumvented that was to have this
multi-skill laws which is just a way of
saying that we we down sample the the
error from our laws and we also add that
to the laws so
instead of having only the the the the
the error between our prediction and the
targets at resolution 256.
um we would also down sample that and
and compute the error and and what that
does is it kind of upweighs
um the low frequency components in that
in that feature map in that in that uh
loss difference
um so it kind of places more emphasis on
having the low resolution image correct
compared to having like all the fine
details correct
um yeah and this was this was that final
uh push that especially for the high
resolution so here you see
um in resolution 256 it's not really
needed although I will say that
it does train more quickly in the
beginning
um so it's kind of also tricky because
because you start to get into
overfitting regimes with this but but
you could say that on the resolution of
256 it's not really needed
um but on 512 it's already more
important uh
because they're adding this loss really
really helps and improves performance
yeah so
the results uh I've shown you some
results already
I think
one of the super cool things now is that
we can have a model that that does text
to image
and it can just be on
uh like the single
the single space that you that you want
to operate on
um so it's it's such a simple model in a
sense because it's
it's still the same uh diffusion model
that was introduced in 2019
um like differences are this fee
prediction
uh this different noise schedule
but but these are like minor right so
the feed prediction is this new
parameterization that you might have
heard about uh the noise schedules just
shift is shifted by this constant
depending on the
depending on the resolution
and and using
using these other architectural tricks
we can have a model that that generates
a pixel space directly and
um performance by by some of the other
models is still better so
um like if you take something like an
image and it does really have uh better
performance and in a sense
it has a really nice way so imagine is a
really nice way it has this super
resolution structure so it has a really
nice way of subdividing this complex
problem of generating an image into
smaller problems
occurs
um our model kind of has to do
everything
uh
at once
um but I will say that
like this performance is very close so
it's like something like 8.3 compared to
7.3 on fid
um
and I think
um yeah it is it is really cool that
um such a simple model with just kind of
the basics
can still work so well on this difficult
task
yeah so so diving into some more results
on on class conditional imagenet which
is a little bit easier to Benchmark
um because the the FID scores are are
like everyone is using the same data and
uh it's kind of it's it's easier to
Benchmark in that sense uh although
overfitting starts to become an issues
so so that's
a difficulty on the other hand
um
but we can see that uh this was state of
the art at at the time of of release I'm
not really sure what has happened since
then
uh but uh
we saw that
um like just just having these simple
tricks and training a large
unit with a Transformer backbone which
we call the the ufit
uh it's got State of the State of the
art performance on these different uh
different data sets I will say this is
without classifier guidance
[Applause]
um so we we specifically optimized our
models without classifier guidance or
any type of guidance
um if you use guidance this also again
kind of changes the FID scale
um
and so if you if you compare models with
guidance you get a different uh ordering
and you might want to actually use
slightly different uh different noise
schedules also
um but but I think that's all besides
the point uh which is that you can get
very reasonable performance with the
original model you don't need a latent
space you also don't need Super
resolutions
at least
not before the before the like say 512
resolution
um so so to summarize
um we're able to to train a single stage
diffusion model on high resolution
images
it makes a lot of sense to experiment
with your noise schedule so if you have
a different
um if you have a different problem
so I said before maybe you only want to
generate textures on top of something
then you might actually want to shift
your schedule in the opposite direction
so instead of going to the
like having something that looks like a
low resolution uh diffusion schedule
you might want to shift it in the
opposite direction because that means
that you're that you're focusing a lot
and all this kind of fine detail that
that matters a lot for textures and
depending on your problem it might make
sense to shift the schedule around
uh another really important uh
kind of takeaway that's not new from
this from this paper in particular but
it's kind of reaffirming something that
we found again and again is that we want
to move the computation uh to the lower
dimensional feature Maps so this is what
we did when we when we said we want to
scale the architecture
at one particular point and the point we
chose was like the 16 by 16
resolution feature maps and this is kind
of a nice sweet spot because if you pick
the 32 by 32 and you do self-attention
there
becomes really expensive
flop wise
and lower than that you get a really
high parameter to to
feature counts so it's also not super
efficient for matrix multiplication
units
so this 16 by 16 uh
resolution is kind of popping up
everywhere as like this magical magical
sweet spot of where to where to do the
computation
um
so that makes a lot of sense if you if
you're trying out new architectures
so I think
that's my last slide I'm not sure if
there's there's any opportunity for
people to
ask questions but I will be happy to
answer them or otherwise feel free to
reach out
hello thanks a lot for this presentation
we have a couple of questions let me
find them
[Music]
okay do normalizing flows still have a
role to play in the current generative
landscape this is a general question
yeah I think I think that's a very good
question
um
so I as I as I introduced myself I said
that I worked on normalizing flows and
when I was working on them they were
trained with the change of variables
formula
and I don't see that happening
uh so often anymore
but what we of course do see is all
these different diffusion model
interpret interpretations that have uh
ode interpretations and and in that
sense uh
continuous time normalizing flow
interpretations
so like score flow and ddim in some
sense also
um
so
a lot of people are looking into these
continuous time flows these these Odes
maybe to improve the sampling speed of
diffusion models
um
theoretically they they should have the
same properties although in practice
um they still lag behind a little bit in
Sample quality
um so they're definitely still active in
in research but also more in relation to
to diffusion models and trained as a
diffusion model and then uh kind of a
normalizing flow can be extracted but
they are really still uh used and
discussed a lot
uh so I I think I think yes although not
in there uh form that they existed two
years ago
have this question do you ever get
issues with the patching approach
involving long-range relationships for
example is being different colors which
was classic issue in older models
um
I think I think we don't know but I
think that so kind of the thing with
patching is that
without patching it's so difficult to
train also it's not only it's not only
an efficiency problem
uh but it's also just
um
yeah I I think it has to do with
training stability but I'm I'm not
really sure about that
um so
I I have not been able to set up a good
experiment even like given given that
someone gave me the compute to really
test a unit at Full Resolution
um
so
I I wouldn't know if the problems are
are bigger in that sense
um I think the model is able to get like
the right eye color uh if if that's like
the specific failure case that you're
looking for I'm just on a broader level
I'm not really sure
if an equivalent unit on high resolution
like would have less of these these
failure cases or if it's really kind of
a thing that you can just
do for free
like given the most optimal salary for
both the high resolution unit and the
patched
patch units
um in our case it was like obvious to do
because the other one didn't train at
all uh or not not that well at least so
yeah
I think for us no
okay
um
is it possible to find the code for your
work somewhere
um unfortunately no but the appendix is
really extensive so
um we made sure to to put the important
details there so kind of like where you
put your normalization layer can
sometimes matter a lot
right so for this you fit architecture
we've kind of detailed
um
where the important
decisions in terms of architecture are
and I've seen some open source
implementations already in pythorch so I
think
it should be possible to to find
something
that's at least close to the original
maybe we could just reproduce stuff in
this print
uh you have mentioned multi-scale loss
for prioritizing low frequencies I read
your paper on blurring division do you
see potential in blurring diffusion to
tackle this issue
uh uh very good question yeah so
it's kind of
it's kind of weird in in blurring
diffusion that it didn't work that well
uh for what we were trying to do
um
and it's
it's yeah it's kind of weird because
I think growing the fusion was taking it
too far Maybe
because
um so what happens in blurring diffusion
is that you you destroy your high
frequency a lot sooner than your low
frequency
um
but you're already doing that with
um standard calcium diffusion even
though that's like it so because
gaussian noise is isotropic if you do
like a norfolkano uh frequency transform
uh still looks the same and all the
frequencies get destroyed at the same
rate
but the point is that natural images
have very low magnitudes and the high
frequencies so kind of by this byproduct
of the image the just natural images
having
not so many low high frequency details
they get destroyed already pretty fast
by by you by this uniform over
frequencies uh gaussian noise
um
and I think what we did in this work was
better
um
uh in the sense that it it focused more
on the problem directly
whereas in blurring the fusion it was
still kind of unclear
what are that kind of what are that so
the the the the the the slant that
natural images have already
uh it's maybe already enough and so the
gains we saw with blurring diffusions
were were just very small
and they were even like they were even
like they needed to train longer so it
was also not really sample efficient
um and this really worked
a lot better so I I guess this uh this
is better but I I can when I was doing
the presentation I said I don't really
like this part I don't really like that
we had to introduce this
um
so I I think I don't know what a better
solution will be but I don't think it's
it's my paper before unfortunately
okay
next question is will this be useful if
the noise was generated by another
noising model as a random idea
um yeah I've seen some things online on
like multi-skill noise
um it's where you have noise on on
multiple resolutions so correlated noise
in a sense
um
and yeah I think I think those things
are
in some ways free flows to what what we
are doing here
um so I think that that makes a lot of
sense
um next question is what do you think of
the consistency models do you think
there could be an exchange between
simple division approach and consistency
models approach
uh yeah I think they're largely
orthogonal as far as I can tell so I
think
um
the the benefits should be able to to
translate uh I think there's there's no
particular components of consist
consistency models that cannot be used
in in this model and vice versa
um
I I am really curious
um for this very low step
uh kind of diffusion alternatives
you still see a loss in performance and
as the data gets more complicated and
higher dimensional those losses are
often bigger
um
yeah so I am I am really curious
um how far you would be able to to push
that if you combined it
and the last question is a bit long
bit long to read the first part and then
I will reflect the second part so the
first one is I find the unit with the
Transformer backbone is somewhat similar
to hourglass Transformers especially the
idea of moving competition to lower
dimensional feature Maps do you do you
think swapping the remaining
convolutional neural net Parts with the
Transformer equivalence would help
improve performance further or is it
increasing computation in the higher
dimensional feature Maps unnecessary
um so I think swapping the swapping the
remaining consonant with Transformers is
not it's kind of tricky to do
efficiently
uh because attention is just expensive
on high resolution feature Maps you
might be able to do some decoupled
attention right so on the on the wife
and hide separately I think people have
done that also
um but I think it's it's all probably
going to be more expensive than just a
few cone players
um
if I think probably increasing
computation that will help improve
performance although like it's difficult
to measure that because on text to image
everybody is using different data sets
and on image Network hitting
uh kind of overfitting issues so we're
testing different things and not really
how well
our models can train
um yeah so I think so kind of to to to
summarize so swapping Transformers for
the conf parts is difficult to get
computationally efficient
um
it might help though so like just adding
more channels on the conflictors or
maybe doing this in a smart way might
help
um
uh improving the improving the
performance and I think there's also I
think you have to talk later by uh by
Ting Chan uh who has a really nice work
on kind of bridging this gap between
high resolution
data feature Maps towards a low
dimensional compute Reservoir so
maybe stick around for that toggle so I
think that that might be
that are the direction that you want to
go into if you wanna
uh go to a full
self-attention architecture
for accepting new talk uh
your your presentation and your paper in
general is amazing I'm looking forward
if there is any if there is going to be
any reproduction of your paper uh in
this prints I will let you know
see you then
yeah thank you so much thank you so much
thank you bye bye
um now I'm going to host apolinario who
is working at hagging face and he's
I think his title is sort of like
generative artists
and he's going to be presenting us
um about uh diffusers Library uh can you
share your screen Polly
also you need to unmute yourself
hello everyone
um yes let me quickly present my screen
right now
I wonder if it's coming from me but like
I'm hearing some music
yeah that's like it's like a background
in the co-working space that I'm at is
it too loud
um
a bit but
I think it's it's it should be okay
uh in the previous presentation Emil had
a bit of a noise in his
microphone so and people were
letting us know about it so it's best if
we don't have the music this time
okay I think here okay it's better yeah
thank you
okay then I will leave you to your
presentation if it's okay
thank you so much
thank you hello everyone uh sorry for
the technical difficulties in the
beginning uh so I'll be here just
presenting a little bit on the diffusers
Library it's more on the a general
approach to the library
um since uh a lot of you that are
participating in the event may be
interested in using the library in the
training examples
um and so I'll go over a bit
on what it is why
it it exists and the philosophy behind
it
um
so the filters is a modular toolbox for
inference and training of diffusion
models
and essentially what that means is that
the idea is to have and provide uh tool
sets and structures for people to train
and inference diffusion models right
um of course hugging face is very well
known for its Transformers Library where
Transformers models were also
harmonized and structured with a toolbox
for for a diffusion for for inference
and for training of the this Transformer
models and when the fusion model started
getting uh interesting popular and
started making sense uh the diffusers
library was created in a kind of
analogous way for diffusion models to
be used and harmonized
um so what are the fusion models I'll go
very quickly over this because I think
um most people participating in this
event May already be aware but the
fusion models are uh processes or
machine learning models that apply a
process of Data Destruction kind of and
then reconstruction so in a way
basically the way it works is that you
learn how to sample from noise through
data
and you do that by training the models
from going from data to noise
and you do that uh via units most of the
cases but as we learned from the last
talk you can do you Vats as well and
other neural networks
um and why the diffusers Library uh had
why why did the the game face team
decided to build the diffusers Library
well the Future model started getting
state of the art results and generative
synthesis uh of images
they uh are not Transformer models even
though they can use Transformers uh and
but they had similar sets of challenges
as Transformers uh each model had its
own implementation with its own research
code the models were scattered around
each one had its different format each
different code base the code base was
research code it wasn't maintained if
one model had like some inference
technique that that was good for it to
run like faster on last vram this was
not replicated to others
um so the diffusers Library will start
to
sort these problems
and well there are a few of
philosophical points about the diffusers
Library
uh one that may seem a bit maybe uh
counterintuitive is usability over
performance
and the idea here is that uh the
diffusers Library prefers something to
be more use usable even if it degrades
the performance a little bit what does
that mean is that it's better if the
code is understandable each block is
independent of which of the another it's
very modular and structured then if it's
super patchy and the hacky but performs
better however as you may be aware uh we
can compatibilize this too so very very
frequently we do have the best
performing
ways of uh using the diffusion models
like say for example with stable
diffusion or with control Nets or many
models that that we support now in the
last release you may may see that we
have like no audio models and all that
in in all of those you we have like a
mix of usability and performance however
whenever we have that trade-off we
prefer usability so that is a bit of the
philosophy behind it but we so far the
the library has been able to tackle both
but doing performance in a way that does
not affect usability so some methods
require further calling and that goes
back to simple over easy
and some people think those are synonyms
like if it's simple it's easy and if
it's easy and simple so what does it
mean that's simple over easy it means
that the Simplicity of each code block
the Simplicity of it of how a pipeline
works or how the the code is implemented
is preferred over how easy it is to use
at the end so what does that mean is for
example if if we have a trade-off
between well
the easiest way would be to detect which
Hardware the person is using and also it
would be to automatically run the
fastest scheduler so people just call
one line off of the the stable diffusion
and everything is already done that
would be super easy
um but it might not be simple because
you would have to make a lot of
assumptions have code that auto detect a
lot of stuff so on that uh we prefer
simple code uh even if it's not the the
easiest uh structure however
um as you might have seen a lot of the
feedback that we get is that it's really
easy to use
diffusers and that's kind of our goal
the Simplicity of the code base is key
for it to be easy to get started with
but not necessarily easy as like the
final user uh perspective over the the
structure for the tool
uh
it's also
thought to be tweakable and contributor
friendly over having too many
abstractions and that is a very
interesting uh philosophy over on this
library that we also borrow from
Transformers
um which is not trivial for many people
uh uh that work with the software
engineering because I think there is
like a one big principle of software
engineering as don't repeat yourself
create like abstractions and only call
create different classes call code Etc
however with uh
with diffusers the idea is that actually
copy pasting code is fine like so you
have many different uh pipelines and
each of them have may have the same code
and the reason is because we want it to
be easy for someone to be able to
contribute a new model to contribute a
new pipeline to contribute a new uh set
of of
elements and for that and also for
someone to tweak like oh I really like
this pipeline but I I wanted to add this
thing or that thing and the
once we have like one code block that
does all and that's easy to understand
uh it's way easier to do those things
while if we had like a layered
abstraction process the the learning
curve for getting started would be too
high
um and also the complexity of the the
software would grow also exponentially
every time there's a new component or
module and how everything is integrated
together
um so yeah it's one of the philosophical
aspects of the library that departs a
bit from what a lot of people may be
used on
um on principles learned about uh
software engineering
and yeah so those are the three
philosophical principles ability over
performance super easy tweakable and
contributor friendly over abstractions
and what's the anatomy of the diffusers
Library well it's divided into three
main aspects and then there is a few uh
other like additional folders and
structures so the anatomy is that we
have the models so those are the kinds
of architectures that the diffusers uh
Library supports and here uh the the
models can be for example the unit to
the in in the it can be all the building
blocks that lead up to a diffusion model
um we have pipelines so the pipelines
are easy to use examples on how to use
models and schedulers for inference so
um this so for example stable diffusion
contains models so you have the stable
diffusion unit stable diffusion vae
stable diffusion uh text encoder and all
those are put together into a pipeline
for you to use and
then we have the noise schedulers and
those are the solvers to the denoising
process uh for the Odes
and they can be plugged on different
pipelines so that's the modular aspect
of the library so if you think about how
the noise schedulers work is that they
try to solve the diffusion process in
the best possible quality in the least
amount of steps possible and it's it's
cool because uh the since there are
independent solvers you can plug them
into any diffusion model or or any
Pipeline and then we have training
examples which are popular libraries and
training techniques so
for example that's where the control net
training code is and essentially on the
examples folders We have dream booths we
have control net and essentially those
are the aspects of the library where we
add uh other examples and other ways to
use the tool including training
and yeah uh this is quite of a short uh
introduction to the diffusers library
and then I will open this more for like
a conversation with the everyone that is
interested in learning a bit more and
wanting to know more details so thank
you so much
foreign
hello
um hello we have uh so you have wrapped
up right I didn't get it wrongly yes yes
yeah cool
um we had only one
um
um sort of like a suggestion
but I don't know if it's to you
it says try to be less Dynamic you to
utilize type annotations I don't know in
in Python I don't know like people just
thought do a lot of typing though
yeah anyway uh there is a question from
Andreas uh could you tell us a bit about
how you convert existing pytorch models
to flex
Yeah so basically the way the the
diffusers Library deals with that is
that the diffusers library is agnostic
towards uh which uh yeah underlying
framework you use this although it is a
bit more Pi torch heavily right now
because that's what has the most usage
and the also a lot of people have access
to that Hardware
but as as we have on this particular uh
setup and regarding the the the we have
quite a bit of of jacks as well and
there is no way to kind of escape the
the process that converting means
actually like we don't have like a full
bulletproof
um uh Pi torch to Jack's conversion that
is like end to end but we do have like
Jax is our second the most used uh
structure on on the diffusers Library
have a lot of support for it
um and you can basically we have some
conversion code that uh I won't go much
in detail here but I can point towards
uh
yeah the the conversion code and you can
see a bit on on how this conversion
Works under the hood uh but yeah
essentially it's it's a bit in a
case-by-case basis where we provide a
conversion code and then uh yeah we have
so conversion we have training script on
both uh Jax and and Pi torch for control
net and we have uh the stable diffusion
weights for both Jacks and uh and and Pi
torch and yeah I'm I'm happy yet to
share the link afterwards uh on how to
on the conversion code where you can
deep dive on how this conversion works
thank you
um
there is a question could you tell a bit
more about noise schedulers
this always written down with an example
I'm sure so basically the idea for an
NYS scheduler is on on diffusion models
is that uh well you start with a full
noisy picture right and then the process
of solving that is that you will on each
step remove a little bit of noise on
that image trying to approach the
conditioning that you have
um so the one of the noise schedulers
the the initial ones was a ddim and
basically uh on on ddim in in the
regular process to have like a thousand
a thousand steps and then on each
individual small step from this thousand
steps you are trying to remove a little
bit of noise and go back to the process
a little bit of noise and go back to the
process uh
and what happened was that this process
worked really well in the early
diffusion models however
um it unfortunately took so a really
long time to do that in a thousand steps
so people started learning that with the
dim you could do uh stop skipping so
that was one technique that people
learned early on where you could reduce
the steps and then more recently many
other solvers uh for because basically
the diffusion process can be seen as an
ode
so uh the other
techniques for solving these equations
such as Euler and uh many uh other that
there is a nice paper about that called
uh yeah for techniques that that is
called K diffusion
um and uh yeah I forgot the name of the
paper right now but it's from Karas at
all and that's why it's K diffusion uh
it's a it's a very nice uh technique uh
for so the paper is called elucidating
the design space of diffusion-based
generative models and I highly recommend
that paper if everyone wants to get a
bit deeper into the
Odes that solve on these equations and
there is a very nice then repository by
Catherine Carlson called K diffusion
which we also support all those solvers
on diffusers uh as well
question is what are the most common
pain points
on diffuse diffusion diffusion models
someone said the diffuser smells uh
would how would you debug a pipeline to
make sure it is working
yeah
um so training a diffusion model from
scratch is very tricky and I think it's
a bit maybe I mean not a discouraging
comment but it's just a process that
requires like for example stable
diffusion required a few hundreds of of
uh a100 gpus with uh yeah a couple of
time and it requires many uh stacking of
techniques so I would say it's a maybe a
bit beyond the scope of of our Sprint
although if someone wants to try and
they have the resources probably the
tpos were going to be given will not be
enough but
I don't want to be discouraging if
someone has a great idea on how to train
a big model into into such a small TPU
and other techniques that's totally fine
but what uh in the scope of this uh
process what may be more normal and and
Pro in the processes that do fit into a
TPU
um are yeah fine-tuning models such as
using dreambooth and other techniques
and also training other models like
control Nets and the good thing about
that is that uh with the with the
training scripts uh provided by
diffusers uh usually you won't have that
many uh issues I think the main pain
points are kind of just the the
quote-unquote traditional pain points of
uh training models which is hyper
parameter tuning so you would need to
find a decent learning rate how many
steps for your model to train
um but to debug the process and to make
sure that everything's working
um the the training scripts we provide
also have processes there so one process
to make sure everything is working right
is saving uh intermediate checkpoint
every x amount of steps so for example
you can train a model and then
um let's say you're training a model for
uh a thousand steps uh or or for a
hundred thousand steps and then you'll
say that for every 500 steps you you
save an intermediate model and you can
also this is also part of the training
code you can sample
examples for each of this uh steps so
for example
um if you see there there is a blog post
uh that is called How to Train control
not on the hugging face blog
and there you can see uh that we track
you can track with tensor boards or you
can track with weights and biases and
basically this allows you to generate an
image for every uh step so you can
follow like kind of perceptually so not
only we're following the loss function
and others but you're also following
kind of like visually and perceptually
how
your training is going and whether your
motto is learning or conditioning in
case of control net and or if it's over
fit or underfit so
um yeah I think that the the the best
way to debug is chat is training for a
bit long checking for intermediate steps
uh if things look going off the rails
maybe reducing or increasing the the
learning rates and trying again
um but yeah I think that training
scripts facilitate this process quite a
bit so you you should only worry more
about running the training script
adjusting your parameters checking the
intermediate training steps but not
really like on on like those bigger
challenges regret when that may emerge
when you think about training a full
model from completely zero
next question is I like the idea of
copying blocks of code but what do you
do if there's an error in the in a block
that has been copied a lot with
abstractions this is easy to fix but
copy requires a lot of groundwork
yeah I think that's one of the drawbacks
of an approach that is not like modular
where if you have a bunch of repeated
pieces of code and you need to change
something in one you have to change
something in other
thankfully uh tools like actual text
editing tools make this way easier like
it's kinda easy to find places where the
code blocks are identical in your code
base and change them all at once and and
save that and then testing is also
really important so the users have very
strict testing structure where
um every time a new code change in the
code base is is made
um we have tests that generate images we
have also integration tests so we make
sure for example that whatever diffuser
implementation matches the original code
so for example every time we change
something in the code we make sure that
the same seed in the same structure
generates the same image compared to the
original code base so basically whatever
we do in the library uh
uh we we test so yeah
um There Is No Escape that if if there
is a bug in a not called in a part of
the code that has been copied into like
20 files have to change this 20 files
but thankfully you don't literally have
to go on each file you can simply like
pull up with the vs code or whatever
um the 20 instances where the code is
the exact same and kind of like uh
modify them all at once and uh and save
and check if it works on on all
pipelines by using the tests
um so yeah it is a bit of a process that
yeah there is uh that's the trade-off
that we're willing to have in in order
to have this tweakable is to use uh
pipelines and structures as opposed to
like saving all this into like one
obstruction and calling that abstraction
and then adding this complexity over
time
uh there's uh three more questions
um
first one is how did you plan the design
of the library as it is about novel
research and it's generally hard to
identify General pattern for modular
software was it acceptable to refactor
for newer models
yeah so the the diffusers team
um has taught quite a bit about like
this whole structure even before stable
diffusion was out
um but the the diffusion model even
though this is a new technology I think
that as we saw in the last talk uh the
diffusion models uh techniques and
structure itself uh didn't change as
much since like the first papers came
out
um there are new tricks like doing
things on on like a latent space like
latent diffusion
um there are other tricks like uh
doing yeah Cascade diffusion and all the
simple diffusion and blurring diffusion
so there's many
um editing processes but the
fundamentals kind of remain the same
where you have like uh the the
schedulers you have the models and you
have
the pipelines that combine them
um so that that structure uh is kind of
it's like the Transformers library right
like in the core you use the
Transformers blocks even though they
haven't changed as much since the
attention is all you need paper
um but we are we have an eye open for
for that
and overall yeah whenever a new model is
out
um for example if the unit requires some
new trick or new strategy we decide kind
of like whether this is part of like the
unit 2D block or if we within like for
example when uh we do Audio models uh
there are new techniques released uh
when we do video models we have a umet
3D uh which was a completely new model
added but they still fit in the overall
Dynamic of the library so adding new
models is not a new process on the
library philosophy is a part of uh you
don't necessarily need to refactor much
to add a new model and on all like if
you have a new technique on an older
model that's also possible to amend so
there's not that there has not been that
much refactoring because a new model was
out because the modularity of the
library kind of like
expects this process of new models
coming out and us being able to plug
things in
thank you there is another question are
there any chance newspapers that you
would recommend for data diffusion
well there is one Camp newspaper which
is the actual latent diffusion paper
itself
um and but that's a bit also it's an
interesting process because the latent
diffusion paper
um has been released uh for the latent
diffusion technique
um but there were many other techniques
added for example the stable diffusion
is based off of the latent diffusion
paper with more tricks
um such as the the the clip text
conditioning that was learned from the
Imagine paper
um then stable diffusion 2 have other
techniques and interestingly enough
there hasn't been yet uh papers like on
an academic setting that like from the
original authors that add to that they
still reference to the latent diffusion
paper so on that I would definitely
recommend the latent diffusion paper
itself and then the the actually
checking the repositories for for stable
diffusion one and two and and seen
incrementally what are the the things
they added so I think those are the most
grounding foundational and then there
are quite a bit of papers on like
different techniques
um that uh yeah so I would recommend a
few papers such as the edifi so it's
letter e and then diff d i f f and then
letter I which is a very interesting
paper of a mixture of expert denoisers
processes
um there's also the Imagine paper but
that's not like a latent diffusion paper
so it's not on that but the thing is
that latent diffusion is just one uh
like for example imagine think about the
the control net paper or the dreambooth
papers
um those work regardless if you are in a
latent diffusion or not so I think there
hasn't been that many research that I'm
aware of of like new developments on
latent diffusion itself however all the
developments on diffusion models uh kind
of apply backwards to latent diffusion
as well
thank you
um next question is what is the
difference between normal fine-tuning
and dream boot fine tuning as they both
seem to be able to find you in a model
to create some artwork in a specific
Style
yeah in a high level the difference is
that with Dreamboat fine-tuning what you
first of all is there are two main
differences one is the fact that you can
keep the model alert knowing everything
it knew before so with dreambooth fine
tuning
um you create kind of a new token that
learns this New Concept that you're
training so uh but it doesn't uh change
the entire model to to that so for
example on traditional fine tuning if
you show like Van Gogh style paintings
to it uh to a model everything you
prompt will be Vanguard style you kind
of like make the model super specialized
in that style but it can only do that
with fine-tuning you with dream Booth
you give it this uh examples of what a
Vanguard style is and you then use the
the new token you trained to add the
Vanguard style
um but if you don't use it the model
still knows everything it uh did know
before so that's one advantage and the
other potentially even nicer or
complementary to that is that on
traditional fine tuning you need quite a
bit of examples so you need to show the
model
um 100 like thousands or dozens of
thousands or maybe hundreds of thousands
of examples while on dreambooth the the
main thing they learned
um and I highly recommend reading the
paper for a dream Booth is that uh you
can you can teach a Model A style or a
person's face or an object for as little
as three to five examples
um by essentially just tuning the the
yeah this this new token and it can
learn uh the concept you kind of are
overfitting on purpose but you blend it
with the general knowledge of the model
in a way that it'll overfit kind of
works so in a high level that's that's
what it is but I highly recommend
reading the paper
thank you and next question is do you
feel that text diffusion models could be
in scope for diffusers to the current
focus seems to be primarily on the image
models
yeah so for the last part of the
question I highly recommend you to go
right now to the GitHub page and see the
latest release 0.15 because we actually
extend diffusers quite a bit from image
to video and and audio with two uh very
cool audio generating models and one
cool video model so that's definitely
uh expanding the scope of from image to
Beyond so I definitely recommend that
regarding text generation I think it
would be in scoping Theory
um right now I haven't particularly seen
very like let's say large language
models that are based on diffusion uh so
like the the llm process I there are
some diffusion based text models that
are
that that I've seen on research but I
think that they are not yet large or
competitive to to other approaches so I
think that the the diffuser library is
not an image only uh uh Library as as
now we have audio we have a video and uh
also even other domains like protein
synthesis is is uh there are some
promising diffusion models there and
others the library is kind of open
there's of course a focus and a scope in
the in a limited amount of dedicated
maintainers
um but I think that so the reason why
text isn't part is not because there is
like a fundamental thing against text
but rather because
as of now they're not like big or
impacts for competitive tax models that
nudge or create some sort of a priority
for those to be added but if if there
there will there will the merge a text
model that is or a large language model
that is diffusion based this would
definitely change the priorities in a
way that quickly consider adding so it's
not philosophically against the library
we just not yet uh I'm not seeing
anything that's uh high in priority
from the
um from the intuition that I get from
the diffusion models it's a bit like you
know you learn the distribution and
everything
um it's a bit like uh in text when you
do like masked modeling and stuff
um it it's it's kind of similar to me in
a way and tomorrow we are going to have
a talk on the Muse paper uh it is about
a masked generative modeling which might
be
interesting for you if you're interested
in text diffusion like they are
unrelated but I would say they are
somehow like the intuition is
sort of uh similar what do you say
yeah I think that that makes sense I
think that the the intuition for like
something like a bird or a mask process
where you like hide some parts and then
you kind of like try to find is similar
to how a diffusion model works and some
people even try to train like diffusion
like bird models but they work just not
as well as the current technique so it's
like it's a nice research process but if
you care about like doing things state
of the art
um yeah I think it's uh still an openly
research question
yeah
and
last question we are going to take and
we will then go on with our next speaker
is
do you think the open source Community
has arrived at the optimal schedulers or
do you think there is more room for
exploitation exploration there let's use
20 steps and seven CFG
um yeah that's a good question
um I do think there's always more place
for exploration
um we see we we see new schedulers
coming up uh the Euler 20 steps seven
CFG D4 of like Alto 111 is pretty good
but
I wouldn't doubt that the community may
find like solvers that go even less
steps like I I think there are people
exploring uh stuff with like 10 steps
um the the classifier free guidance of
seven at least for stable diffusion I
think there are some like lower and
upper bounds of like five to nine but I
I uh but there's also some people
working on stabilizing the image
generation on way higher cfgs so I think
there there are still open research
questions there
um but I think we're solidifying however
it's it's good to to remember that
stable diffusion is one model very good
amazing model but
um we are going to see potentially more
models uh on on diffusers for attach to
image and then all this uh we we need to
see whether this learnings translate to
them so it's a kind of interesting
um process to to move forward to uh I
just see in the chat one question that I
will answer really quickly uh
on how well does dreambooth learn from
layout of images and on that one I'll
just say that it can learn that but
probably for that you want to do
something like a control net or a text
to image adapter
so
yes uh with that I thank everyone and
yeah I hope you have a great uh event
and a great uh participate in this
amazing Sprint thank you also uh given
this is in the scope of this Sprint when
you think about it I'm not going to
remove this question so I feel like
dream boot is good for like learning
Concepts and if you would like to learn
a layout of images sort of maybe you
could use control net as poly said and
maybe you could actually try this in
this Sprint maybe add this as an idea
and try to see if it works using
powerful tpus and Jacks and diffusers
now we have a speaker from stability
hello
hi thanks for uh thanks for having me
thanks for accepting this peek would you
like to introduce yourself a little
yeah I'm my name is Zion English I'm a
machine learning engineer at stability
and
um
yeah I've been in the community for a
while
um
and uh I'm I'm glad to be here because I
know that the space moves fast and the
whole point of my talk is I want to talk
to the person I was a year ago or two
years ago and that's the person who is a
developer or maybe like finishing school
and they're interested in this topic but
they maybe haven't been able to keep up
with the latest advancements
um but they they want to contribute so
that's really who this talk is for and
we're going to get all on the same page
about what it means to control stable
diffusion some of the techniques and we
would have like a little bit of a a high
level overview of how stable diffusion
works so that we can uh maybe brainstorm
ways that we can can break it and like
add new features
great would you like to share your
screen so I can yeah
yes yes
all right
um can you see this yeah
yeah with your presentation go back
all right thank you
so
um yeah so the talk is like what does it
mean to control stable diffusion
um
in the past year we've made like
tremendous uh progress in generating
realistic images from text descriptions
and we've seen like a lot of adoption
from the community by fine-tuning on
specific tasks
um you know as previously spoken we have
dream Booth or you know more general
fine-tuning for people who have a very
specific art style that they want to
generate images in but you know the base
model of stable diffusion maybe isn't
aware of that technique
or they uh you know really just they
have a very specific vision of what they
want and they can train it in and we've
even seen like more creative uh you know
applications of this like refusion which
kind of trained on I think like
spectrograms and then they were actually
able to like reconstruct like audio
files from the spectrogram which is
pretty cool because it means that like
maybe there's like more potential for uh
stable diffusion as a backbone but
um all of these things are still limited
by the fact that they can only generate
images by feeding a text description is
right I mean that was the original goal
and stable diffusion has accomplished
that but now that we're able to do that
pretty well we need to start thinking
about okay what are some other ways that
we can start gaining control over the
image generation processor
or image generation process and the
solution is to control the model with
adapters and that's kind of what we're
going to start to talk about here today
but first as I said I don't want anybody
who is more on the developer side and
trying to get in to feel like they are
lost in this talk so we're going to have
a refresher on how stable diffusion
works
and
um you know this isn't an exhaustive
explanation so if you do find yourself
wanting a little bit more I've left
um some keywords that you can Google if
you're more interested in the math I
really like outliers YouTube channel
um just give that a Google he does
really nice like three blue one brown
type videos on
um on these topics and if you're more
interested in like hey like I just need
to see some code uh on how stable
diffusion Works
um crocking stable diffusion uh if you
Google it it's not the first result but
you'll see a notebook down there open
that notebook it's been like I even find
myself going back to it every once in a
while when I needed like a refresher on
you know something specific in the
pipeline because it's so explicit in uh
and how it kind of shows you how stable
diffusion works but
at a very high level overview we have uh
three parts we have the text encoder
that's the thing that you feed your
caption into and then you have the unit
and that's the thing that kind of works
on latents it it's kind of where most of
the magic happens and then at the end
you have an auto encoder and that's the
thing that kind of takes the unit's
output and matches that to the actual
image space
um some things to like you know be aware
of like this is a very linear pipeline
right we can only guide stable diffusion
by feeding in uh information that little
blue diamond there once it leaves that
we're at the mercy of the unit and the
autoencoder to kind of make our images
for us and this is a limitation and it
it kind of manifests itself as a lack of
control
uh when we were making like you know
these models like the idea that we could
generate images from text was so novel
and fun
um that you know I think a lot of people
just you know push towards that but now
that we're there you know
I think it's really important that we
start to think about ways we can control
stable diffusion other than just text
so again let's dive in a little bit more
and I've High I'm going to highlight
things in these diagrams because I one
of the themes of this talk is I want you
to remember that in a model
at any given point if you kind of freeze
the process of like you know feeding
information through the neural network
at any given point they're just matrices
they're just tensors that you can
manipulate in any way you want and uh
when you do so you start to kind of
think of creative ways that you can
inject information but we'll get to that
later so uh again let's just kind of get
through uh some of these parts the text
encoder is uh actually from clip we've
kind of taken that Frozen text encoder
and we actually use the text embedding
so like the last layer or the second to
last layer of clip that's what we
actually feed to the next part
as a conditioning Vector so in addition
to the kind of noisy latent that we're
going to be optimizing we kind of give
the unit a little hint as to what we
actually want to generate by using this
text encoder and
um
for those of you who want kind of like a
visual in your head or like a code
visual in your head uh it's just like a
one by seven six eight or a one by ten
twenty four one by five twelve uh Matrix
of information from clip that we're
feeding into stable diffusion
and then we get to the unit which is
kind of where a lot of the magic happens
as I said
um traditionally a unit would take in
images and output images
um sometimes input images for example
was like a brain scan and then the
output was like a segmentation mask
outlining a tumor in that brain but in
stable diffusion we take in latents and
we output latents and
you know maybe that's not intuitive to
you as to like why that's important but
the idea is that it's just a lot more
efficient to work in the latent space
um instead of the pixel space because
the latents are smaller and so it can
fit more of them in and it's faster
um but in general a unit is just
compressing and uncompressing
information
uh and so this here's another point at
which we can you know start to go in and
tweak stuff and uh you know say hey well
you know what if we focused on you know
maybe these bottom three layers here
like that's really where we want to
start injecting information
um
yeah and uh so then oops
then we get the last part
um you know very simply the auto encoder
is just what decodes the latents
generated by the unit into an actual
image so this is how we you know get
from the you know amorphous you know
nobody knows what's going on late in
space to something that we can actually
visualize
um and one thing to note is that the
unit process kind of happens over
multiple steps but the variational
autoencoder just you know is like a
One-Shot process that you feed in the
latens and you get out an uh an output
image
but that kind of you know begs the
question like why even bother control
these controlling these models because
uh you know it's pretty good at taking
in a text description and outputting an
image well
you know if you add control it lets the
human Express themselves more
effectively and that's always a good
thing right because the goal with these
models should never be in my opinion to
replace a human you know
we saw the camera like help people
capture what they want and we saw
Photoshop help people you know do uh
very creative illustrations and stuff
like that it's never uh the all these
things should be tools to like help the
human Express themselves more
effectively uh and like you know when we
add more knobs to tweak it it creates
opportunities for integration and other
software or maybe a workflow that didn't
exist previously but I think one of the
most important things that we're all you
know excited about is that often it
improves the quality of outputs and
through doing that we kind of enhance
the user experience if you will
and that's what's really exciting
but
um as we start to get towards more
tangible stuff like what is controlling
a stable Fusion even look like
um I wanted to give some real world
examples of what this might mean so a
sketch adapter like the one pictured
here uh might help a concept artist
quickly iterate on ideas without having
to dedicate too much time to a specific
idea so like if they wanted to generate
you know 10 different concepts for some
new cyberpunk character they could you
know quickly just say like oh okay like
I kind of want the face structure to be
like this and then maybe they're wearing
a hat maybe they're not they can do that
fairly quickly almost as like a warm-up
exercise and then use a control net
sketch adapter to turn their sketch into
like a kind of a final render or maybe I
shouldn't use the word final but they
can almost visualize what the final
product might look like and then they
can say hey okay yeah I really like
where this one's going let me spend more
time on that one another way we might do
it is through a pose adapter so you
could imagine
um
you know some people who want to make a
movie or something like that in their
garage and they can actually get on a
green screen and start acting out and
then they can use a pose adapter to kind
of map those body movements into uh a
new world if you will with some kind of
fine-tuned uh image model or stable
Fusion model
um and finally you know a depth adapter
that's kind of able to take in depth
information might help an architect
render a scene and a style adapter might
reimagine product photo shoots
but now we have to get to the how right
because now that we're acquainted with
some of the ways that stable diffusion
works and why we might want to control
it well how we actually adding these
knobs specifically well there's two uh
popular methods for doing so there is uh
T2i adapters and control net we'll give
a brief overview of both of them but
like I really want to focus on why they
work not so much you know any specific
reason or any any specific one
so first control net kind of mimics the
structure of stable diffusion's unit and
I personally really like this one
because it was like it was explicit it
was very obvious like hey you have this
layer and the controller and then you
have this layer on the control net and
then those are talking to very similar
layers in stable diffusion and so your
at least for me it was like kind of like
okay yeah I could see how we're able to
kind of turn stable diffusion into a
marionette and uh get it to do what we
want but as you start to work with it
you realize that there's a lot of
overhead associated with kind of
replicating the unit structure if you
have a trainable copy if you notice like
we're kind of making exact copies of
these down sampling blocks
if you project that out into the future
and we start to you know follow this
trend of larger and larger models uh
something like control net become it
kind of scales with that and you start
to you know get a lot of overhead
associated with larger models and beyond
that the paper recommends fine-tuning
the model after training control net for
best results and so like that's kind of
like another reason why uh control that
may be uh more of a
um
you know more of a task than you might
have originally imagined and so in the
context of this like Community Sprint
it's important to be aware of like if
you if you only train the control net
then you might not be getting the best
results and so you might want to try at
least my recommendation is T2i adapters
which I feel like haven't gotten as much
love in the community maybe they have
more recently but
um
they take a different approach they say
like hey let's just uh make our own
feature extractor uh architecture and by
doing so we can control the size of the
model
and you know this might be less
intuitive as to why it works but the
same concept is there we're going to be
generating
um some feature vectors
here that we can inject into unit layers
and that's kind of the general theme
that we'll see
and uh beyond that there's no need at
least uh what we've found so far to
fine-tune the original unit after
training a T2i adapter
as long as you're kind of working within
the same uh base stable Fusion model it
seems to work that you can take the same
T2i adapter and utilize it in that model
and the same is generally true of
control net it's just that
um
from as far as I understand and you know
in my in my research like control net uh
seems to work better when you fine-tune
the unit as well and I think what's
exciting about T2i adapters at least as
an idea is that it kind of frees up the
user to be creative in the way that they
build out that feature extractor
architecture
uh so
again it's kind of something I've hinted
at what is the general theme of this and
that's really just to get to the basics
uh you really just need a input image
and an output image that's what you're
going to be controlling or training your
control Network on uh is you just need
something to map to something else and I
think sometimes we get lost in the
billions of parameters the the cosine
schedulers and and exponential moving
averages like you know just kind of like
take a step back and say like hey what
do we want uh what do we want to do and
how can we boil that down to a simple
this is going to map to this
uh it you know just to kind of give you
some basic examples like sketch to a
final image a depth map to a final image
that's all you needed to train those
sketch and depth adapters
um and kind of as you go through the
community Sprint remember like try to
save time if possible uh try to keep the
unit Frozen you'll probably find that it
trains a lot faster if you don't have to
you know compute gradients through that
unit and then also you know uh don't be
afraid to be creative you know
extract features and maybe ways that
aren't conventional and just see what
happens I think you could get a lot of
cool results just by messing with those
uh a T2i adapter architectures and so I
kind of want to uh leave you with some
ideas or challenges about ways you might
add more control to stable diffusion
like what if you just reversed uh the
sketch adapter what if you took an image
and then just made it had stable Fusion
draw sketch and then you could then use
the original sketch adapter to kind of
turn that sketch into an image and now
you have this fun pipeline where you
know you have somehow added control but
now have uh less control and an artistic
aspect and you can have some fun ideas
and like image variation or something
like that
could you improve animations a call out
to all like the deform enthusiasts can
you get rid of that flicker or improve
like temporal consistency
uh is there a way to improve the
readability of text outputs Could you
teach stable diffusion to fix its
Infamous flaw of drywall text
um how about some style transfer
techniques that nobody's thought of you
know uh if you have not read up on you
know how style transfer works and you
don't know what you want to do I would
encourage you like hey can you come up
with some new way to do style transfer
and if you don't know what I mean by
that like trying to do like uh the Mona
Lisa in the style of Van Gogh or
something like that like that would be
really cool
uh and maybe like Could you teach stable
diffusion to automate a task at your
existing job
um and again not to replace you but to
help you do your job better
or more efficiently so uh you know in
conclusion stable diffusion is cool but
it is limited currently in terms of
human input uh increasing the user's
control will ultimately lead to better
results and
um really if you want to do that you
know you just be uh persistent and try
to hijack the unit or maybe the text
encoder or the variational autoencoder
um but
um you know as we've seen the most
um uh current methods attack the unit if
you will like attack is kind of a loaded
word but
um yeah I encourage you all uh to just
have fun experiment and don't remember
to start with the basics and keep things
simple
thank you uh do we have any questions
thank you
um we have a question it's um
I'm not familiar with T2i adapters but
do you think something like Laura could
be adapted to inject control information
also uh potentially uh I you know
admittedly I haven't looked into lore
too much I've kind of like I did the
once through on the GitHub repo a while
back but
um I don't see why there wouldn't be
some reason why you could get creative
and do that
um as far as I understand Laura is kind
of like a distilled version of the model
and
um you know you might have to kind of
figure out ways you can project
some layer to fit the you to kind of
match the units uh shape because if you
want to uh if you want to kind of hijack
the unit as I was saying you need to
make sure that those layers shapes match
but
um yeah I would encourage you to try it
and see what happens foreign
thank you we have another question do
you think unconditional generation
without any input at all provides better
outputs
uh unconditional generation without any
input
um I think I mean like from a from a
noise seed
in a way and not texting but oh
um
uh I think I think maybe I I don't know
that I necessarily agree with that but
um maybe I don't fully understand the
the question
um
like I'm kind of like I'm almost
imagining like those like
um like imagenet diffusion models that
used to exist or like an Eminence like
diffusion model I think those might they
might look like they provide better
outputs but
um again like it might just be because
it's kind of like over fit on like you
know over fit on like specific things
and it's just able to generate those
really well and maybe when we have
conditional generation on text and
something like that we start to see the
flaws in the diffusion process
um I do see this comment like they were
simpler times when we just had
unconditional image Generation
Um but yeah
hopefully that answered your question I
think it's harder to get right like from
your experience but yeah
I have a question what is the next big
thing at stability
I don't know if I was cleared to talk
about any of that
um
I think I can tell you we're working on
um you know controlling stable diffusion
and
um we've been bouncing around a lot of
fun ideas and so I I'm excited to be
able to share with you what we've been
working on
um we've been doing a lot of like uh
groundwork so that we can then move fast
and like kind of just throw everything
at the wall and see what sticks
um so uh yeah I think you guys will have
fun once we once we get start pushing
some stuff out
there is
a question but it's it's it's for
everyone but also maybe for you but if
you replace the bottleneck of unit model
with Transformer and then injected
information using T2i adapters is that
already out there yeah so I love this
one because it's like it reads thinking
outside the box
um I
in general there's no reason why you
shouldn't be able to do this
uh in practice I
I hate to like uh you know
say this but uh bottlenecks were kind of
there to
be a low overhead way to improve uh unit
models and so adding a Transformer is
almost like uh the polar opposite of
that like you're kind of adding in this
like model that needs a lot of training
and it's big
um but uh again like I love the idea
because it's very creative
um I don't if you get it working like
amazing like please reach out to me
um but yeah I would imagine that you
would run into some some uh like
training stability issues or just you
know you don't have enough data or some
you know something like that
I don't know about the TTY adapters but
in the first talk of today we we had
Emil uh working on simple diffusion and
um
he replaced the unit model with uh
some
um MLP with self-attention which is like
a simple Transformer so you might want
to
uh so basically we are going to record
this uh talk like this is being recorded
and then you can watch it uh watch the
beginning of it if you haven't watched
yeah that'd be cool
thank you so much for coming
um I really enjoyed your talk and I like
the whole sentimental thing behind it
it's like I enjoy uh the message as well
thank you I appreciate it and uh thanks
for everybody for uh listening
have a nice day
bye bye
now we will have a thing
um
also Christian said didn't a simple
decision paper do exactly this yes
um you didn't miss that
so let's have thing hello
[Music]
how are you
good how are you thank you so much I was
looking forward to your talk
um can you share your screen yes let me
do not
can you see my screen now yes
I will leave you with your talk then
okay thanks
hi everyone
um this is tin Chen
happy to present our work um uh you know
extending diffusion model for discrete
data as well as high dimensional
Generations this is join worker with uh
recent uh Jeff Allen David lalasarap
from Google research printing
so I guess these are fairly General uh
topic on
introductory slides on the diffusion
model but I guess most of people are
already familiar so I will quickly go
over it uh basically you have this
process that in the forward Parts you
define the data to the noise and the
backward path you define a reverse path
you define the noise to the data and the
data to the noise is controlled by
basically this formula and the reverse
inference process is basically you
jumping from a noisy state to an
estimate of an x0 on ipstrom the noise
and then you jump a little bit uh
earlier to the closer to the data and
then you repeat this process until you
arrive in the data in order to do that
you basically train a denoising function
a bit more specific uh you train on this
tasks with a few lines of code for
training uh so basically you sample
noise and Sample time step in this case
I was using the continuous formulation
so you sample time continues between
zero and one and then you get the
corrupted data like this and then you
train a network to estimate the original
image so that's that's the training and
with net training then you get this uh
denoising function or score function
where you can use to reverse the process
and again this is a fairly simple uh
algorithm except that there is this
updating rule kind of like a gradient
descent how to update you know you have
no gradient but how do you update your
parameters in here updating the
prediction of the generated image so I
will leave uh with a few pseudocode here
but basically you know you get this
process of denoising uh from the noise
and then you wrap it into the data so
hopefully that's clear
um that's the diffusion models and uh
Now One issues with diffusion models I
think there are two um that we try to
address one is that they are pretty good
at generating continuous data uh
especially in the the the image RGB
continuous values but it's limited in
generating High dimensional uh discrete
data like text or the the penalty mask
which we will talk a little bit about
and they also require multiple stages of
uh
training for high dimensional data like
high resolution images so we'll also
touch on that um
so the first thing how do we generate
the square data there has been some work
using diffusion model on the continuous
uh embedding of the square data to
generate them so here we introduce
another way which is a simpler and
demonstrate that this can scale a
diffusion model to generate one million
or two million discrete tokens at a time
or in a few steps like
10 or 20. okay so um the idea is fairly
simple you still keep the continuous uh
diffusion model in terms of continuous
State space
um continuous time step input is also
continuous now how do you generate how
do you use that to generate a discrete
data so discrete data can be represented
as tokens right like token ID equal to
five for this specific token what you
can do is you just turn it into binary
bits but that's still binary that's not
continuous so one thing that we kind of
do is here is that we just treat these
binary string as continuous floating
points which might seem a little bit
counterintuitive but there is some toy
example in the paper to show you know
this is possible to do
um with a very strong uh continuous
generating model
um and then this is a training time you
just train on this analog bits and they
are binaries but essentially then they
consider as floating points numbers by
essentially binaries and then in the
inference time you generate those uh
analog bits so there might be some you
know Precision differences here like you
know generate
1.05 but that's okay you can stretch
holding them to the binary again and
then turn that into uh this to uh
discrete token
so this is basically like uh you know uh
applying uh Transformer to images what
do you do uh you just tokenize the image
and the fill that into Transformer so
this is like apply continuous diffusion
model for discrete data you just uh make
you have a data preprocessing make them
into a continuous analog bits and then
you use a standard diffusion model and
yeah to make that a little bit more
concrete
um you know this is the like two line of
code change in order to use this idea of
um you know turning the integer to
Binary bits and then you convert them
into floating points and then you know
we properly scale them
has shift and scale them and then you
you know uh just sustain their diffusion
model and the inference time again this
is a one one line code change where at
the end of the generation use just
holding them and then turn them turn the
binary bits into the integer uh discrete
token so this works fine it's not uh
it's not amazing so one thing we add to
improve the model is this so-called
self-conditioning which turned out to
also be um helpful in the in a
continuous setting
um but just in general
um a reverse diffusion process you can
see now we're jumping around the state
space you know to x0 and then
um or equivalently is Epsilon
um and then we're jumping back and so we
basically throw away the intermediate
computation of estimation on x0
um and then the idea here is that why
don't we just leverage your previous
prediction like for the diffusion model
they already estimating the x0 maybe we
can just reuse them as a conditioning
and we know that for a diffusion model
like good conditioning is pretty
important so maybe this will be helpful
so that's the kind of like motivation
and the way to implement this is uh in
the training time is fairly simple I
would say uh it takes uh maybe 10 uh to
25 percent of uh compute increase but
that's not a lot
um so basically you know what you do is
you um you first have a x predict or
asking so let's say we predict x0 here
and then with some probability you're
going to uh you know uh make a first
make a forward path of prediction of X
predict and then you
um condition on that
um for the the next forward pass where
you actually Define a loss and then we
uh to save the compute
we don't actually uh back propagate
through this uh the predicted x0 uh or X
predict here so basically you have two
forward Parts uh with one without uh one
of the the first one without any uh
gradient flowing through them so that's
basically in the training change
in the inference time it's almost come
for free basically you know you maintain
the X predict uh over the course of the
generation and they start with zero and
then you know anytime you make a
prediction of x0 you know you just reuse
them as a conditioning variable you know
uh using the channel can concatenation
here
yeah so how how well does it work
um basically uh we can compare to uh
state of art discrete image generation
because generating images uh you know
require High dimensional like uh you
know here we start with 32 by 32 um a
Siva 10 which already give us like three
thousand or near four thousand tokens
these three tokens and we want to
compare them to some of the state of our
investors uh
so there are some continuous pixel
modeling methods and also modeling pixel
as a discrete uh partial ordinal pixels
or 40 categorical pixels which means
every token
um is equally uh
uh you know a distance from other tokens
so you can see that we beat state of art
uh quite significantly especially from
the categorical pixels and compared to
this Auto regressive Transformer that
train um
um the the image uh you know predict one
sub pixel at a time we actually have an
FID number
so we also scale this to 64 by 64
Imaging images consider them as a
discrete uh
categorical images
and uh to the best of our knowledge we
didn't find any Baseline report any FID
any scale which is like a lot of
discrete tokens and then we compare
basically to continuous diffusion models
and we see there is a gap obviously
because uh we didn't fully utilize the
relationship between different pixel
intensities by treating them as let's
say continue a discrete categorical
pixels
but if you look at the samples so on the
left is the continuous modeling
modeling pixels as continuous numbers
and on the right you model them as a
categorical variables I think it's fair
to say the quality is is pretty good
okay so one concern um that you might
have is like the the final stretching
thresholding step might be introducing
additional errors like how can model
um a diffusion model continuous
diffusion model model the the binary
bits now well it turned out that the the
the the a good continuous generating
model like a diffusion model they can
they make pretty good commitment like
they don't uh just generate something in
between
um like negative one and the one here
because you have two choices in the
training data so in a sampling time you
know all these are sampling time but
with different coding so you can see
most of them are very uh concentrated on
the on the two strings so if you do not
thresholding you it's unlikely that you
uh
you know introduce additional loss if
the model is training well they know how
to pick a site basically
um so yeah self-conditioning is also
useful for not just the discrete
prediction as you can see in the first
two figures with
um self-conditioning like the blue and
the green bar is FID is better so the
lower is better especially uh well you
know if you look at the best case here
and even for the um continuous Imaging
at 64 by 64 images I will still see some
significant Improvement especially when
you're predicting x0
so yeah self-conditioning itself can be
a useful technique and we also apply
this to
um image captioning tasks on Coco
where you know generating the captions
using a few steps of diffusions so
um actually we're modeling nice 60
bits but you only
uh you only visualize two um
a few tokens here as you can see that
with a significant maybe 10 step of
diffusions you generate the reasonable
captions
foreign
model is to actually model High
dimensional discrete data
um in which case like taking here you
have the uh the panotic segmentation
task where we predict the periodic mask
a discrete which are discrete tokens and
they can be uh one million or two
million tokens which is Out Of Reach for
um you know Auto regressing models
um you know just if you're just training
to predict the mask one by one one token
by another token in here you can see
that the visualization is pretty good
compared to
um some existing techniques which are
very specialized for the task uh we're
doing uh reasonably well if we compare
the similar models
and this is uh demonstration of another
data set called cityscape
uh you can see even there are like a
very densely populated area with many
people working and they still do a
reasonably good job
and yeah this can be uh quite
straightforwardly uh
you know you send it to video where you
just predict the periodic basket of the
video and you can see this overlaying
The Mask to the image to the video is
doing reasonably well
yeah and and again so these are like
generating discrete tokens uh of of mask
and it seems to work pretty well
okay so that's the first part that we uh
use so
analog bits to extend the existing uh
diffusion model to generating High
dimensional discrete data and the other
thing we wanted to address here is how
can we scale this diffusion model to
higher resolution images or just
generally High dimensional data you know
using
less Cascade steps
so there are a few challenges in scaling
diffusion model to higher resolution
images
and you know uh these investors require
multiple stages
I think there are two challenges the
first one is the architecture
um like uh you you know the existing
ones like unet and the Transformer or
unit plus Transformer some people call
Trans unit
um
and then the model itself might also
have some kind of
issues in preventing uh achieving the
skating
so so what are the drawbacks of
Transformers when we apply to
um
diffusion model generating High
dimensional or high resolution images
so one thing is uh Transformer you know
they have quadratic computation uh by
self-attention and even a linear
computation of free forward Network to
the number of tokens is already pretty
expensive when you consider High
dimensional data like high resolution
images
um so is this thing work around this by
uh better tokenization
but we here we propose another some
orthogonal angle in tackling this
problem which is so-called adaptive
computation
so basically uniform computation might
not be optimal for the following two
scenarios one is the you know
information might not be distributed
uniformly in the image like we'll see
here you have a lot of Blue Sky which
arguably don't need that much of
computation but you also have something
that's high contrast to where you need
to do more especially in the edgy part
you need to do more refinement so that's
the first reason and the other is the
you know the redundancy of information
like you know if you look at a video
generation case where you generate
multiple frames uh so in here like the
video prediction
you know
um
only some part of the the uh the person
here are moving and the rest of it is
psychostatic background so you know you
have a rather redundancy you want to
focus focus on the compute to the region
where actually things are moving right
so basically this for these two
scenarios we want to allocate compute
adaptively to the data example like uh
like whatever in the data you want to
generate you want to allocate the
compute adaptive to that
so in order to do that we propose this
uh so-called interface Network which is
uh a variant of Transformer I would say
um that um
that kind of factorize the compute
computation into two parts one called
the interface so the interface is
basically you you know you take the
image or video and you tokenize them
into small patches so this is um this
can be a learned tokenization or this
can be just the the pixel you know
reshaping the patch into some Dimension
and then do a linear projection and then
you basically have the interface token
and the nation tokens are a set of
learnable tokens they are not
um associated with the data initially
and then you have this process of
reading the information from the tape uh
on the interface into the latents and
doing some Transformer processing and
then you use a cross attention to write
the information back to the interface
and doing some very local computation on
the interface uh basically the MLP on
the interface token then you repeat this
process basically so this eliminates the
r2r interaction in the standard
Transformer if you consider this
interface as
as the tokens for Transformer then you
have all to all interaction
between them and here you basically
routing the information to the Nathan
where a set of compact tokens you can do
majority of the computation there and
then you run the information back uh to
the interface for some more computation
okay I'll be more uh specific on the
computation process you initialize the
interface with tokenization of an image
or video and then you use cross
attention uh to read information into
the latents where you do a set of
processing and then you write back to
the uh with another cross attention
followed by MLP tuner
interface and then you repeat this
process so one thing to notice this
resembles uh the perceiver i o which
they do one read and process on the
right here we have multiple rewrite
steps that's one difference the other is
that we incorporate this um
Nathan self-conditioning Warner nations
are initial initialized with previous
step latents which I will talk about in
one or two slides so basically if we
don't consider the uh the the NATO
initialized from previous steps uh this
interface network has a problem which is
that information has to be transferred
between the interface and the data then
this incurs an overhead
which can overshadow the benefits so
intuitively you know we as humans also
have a very similar co-star problem like
if we move to a new location we have to
familiarize ourselves in the new context
before we can you know reliably or
efficiently
um infer relevant information
so in the recurrent computation scenario
you know we where there is a persistent
Global context
so we can actually uh
you know amortize the cost of building
this meaningful Nation
and as well as routing of the
information
yeah so another Finding here is that the
diffusion models are actually uh very
similar to a recurrent Network because
the reverse generation process of the
diffusion model you know you just apply
the same network to uh slightly changing
uh input many many times so this
motivate us to reuse the Nations build
up from the last time step you know very
similar to a recurrent Network again
this is also similar to latent
self-conditioning where you don't want
to throw away the computation you built
from previous time step
um because they are similar so they
probably can help you the good thing
here is that we uh we don't need to
train uh the model with standard bad
propagations through time as in
conventional uh transfer recurrent
Network
so basically what we do here is very
similar to self-conditioning but do it
on a latent space so we initialize the
Nathan as zero during the training and
then we first do a forward pass of a
noise image and we infer the latent
and then we're going to put the stop
gradient on the Nathan and then pass it
into
um you know another forward pass here
where you know you condition on the the
previous uh latents as well as the
learnable embedding of the initialized
natives try to denote its language again
and again this doesn't this increase the
training costs probably by 10 to 20
percent
and uh in the inference time it is
almost for free because
um you know every time you have the
Nathan at every
um step and then you just pass that
around during the inference process
and this is the kind of basically the
pseudo code and again you can see in the
changes highlighted in blue uh uh quite
small
okay so another issue I think uh is
probably mentioned by uh Emil in
earlier's talk uh of his work simple
diffusion so similarly we we find that
in the noise scheduling uh player
important role and then when you scale
up the image sizes uh you know the same
the optimal noise schedule for a smaller
image might be sub-optimal for a larger
image because the task becomes simpler
as you can see here with the same noise
uh level
um you can see the image of a higher
resolution just contain more information
about the original image
so uh in the penaltical work we propose
this input scaling trick which you know
just scale the input to making the task
harder
this is actually turned out to be
equivalent of scaling or Shifting the
lock signal to noise ratio curve as you
can see here in terms of implementation
is fairly simple you know you just
before you add in the noise you just
scale your input
and then Additionally you can also
normalize the noise the input to make
the variance the same uh
uh which is the optimization of the
denoising neural network
okay how well does this work
um
so basically we achieved some uh pretty
good results
um single stage end-to-end image and a
video generation based on pure pixels so
here we compare to some
CDM ADM paper which are
very strong baselines that we compare to
and the uh 3D unit from video diffusion
work so we can see that we get a very
significant reduction of flops
um at the same time achieving better
fids so one thing to highlight if we
look at like uh 1K by 1K images we have
uh even with patch size of eight by
eight we have 16k tokens
then the data we use is actually only
256 latent tokens so you can see that if
you do a Transformer of 16k tokens that
would be extremely expensive during the
training but uh with this data
projection you can get away with a
smaller uh a fewer compute as well as a
much better memory efficiency
so here is a comparison you know again
with the
architecture as well as input scaling
trick that we can get the model to
generate the 1K by 1K images uh in a
single stage training
and single stage end-to-end training
and here are some samples at 512 from
image Nets and 768 Dimensions so as 1K
and this uh kind of visualization shows
that how adaptive computation is
occurring so you can see that read the
tension from the interface to the latent
space as shown here uh for large
Partners concentrated
um the object boundaries uh as well as
like yeah but basically the place where
you inspect you know the models to do
more computation and from the background
you can see there's fewer except except
for a few blocks that they did too
because they also need to refine the
background
uh it's just that for major PC part
especially the
um the later stage of the diffusion
process there the model looks at the
um the objects much more
which means uh concentrating the
computation to the object boundaries and
you know high contrast area
so we also have some ablation but
basically trying to show that you know
self-conditioning negative
self-conditional is is pretty critical
here
um and the multiple rewrite blocks are
important as you can see here if you
just have one read write
um is is much worse
and uh it is pretty it's relatively low
bus to a range of uh tokenization as you
can see here
okay just to conclude so we basically
improve the division model for discrete
data generation enable it to generate
the 1 million or two million uh discrete
tokens
with relatively few steps like 10 or 20.
so we also discussed a few ways to scale
uh diffusion model for higher resolution
images
um including some architecture
Improvement as well as noise scheduling
yeah here are some
resources so uh paper
that's discussed
thank you very much
that's all for my talk thank you thing
we have few questions
um and then we are going to close this
stream
so one question is what is the intuition
behind analog bits rather than an
embedding layer
well yeah so analog beats are simpler
right so you don't need to learn the
embedding first
and uh I think the uh the intuition is
basically if you have a very strong uh
continuous generating model it should be
able to generate the analog bits because
just imagine that uh first if you have a
weak a generative model it might
generate something in between like you
have zero and a one imaginary 0.5 right
but but strong generating model like
diffusion model it learns to choose a
site it would commit to zero or one so
initially you know you learn to choose
zero and one uh to satisfy some local
constraint but as the model gets better
so it should be able to figure out the
global constraint like you don't
generate things that doesn't make sense
uh globally so I think
um I think in a limit a continuous model
is able to handle analog bits really
well but how well we can make it work it
depends on you know practical
constraints so in this paper we go with
this because of the intuition that you
it should work in the limit but we try
to just propen the limit here in this
work and it turned out at least for
another panelistic segmentation task
where you have one million or more
tokens uh this is actually work pretty
this works pretty well and you don't
need to additionally learn an embedding
layer which probably is more complicated
and also uh might require more memory
depends on the setting
um as well as you know when you learn
the embedding model you need to
decantize and quantize maybe they also
incurs some uh you know conversation
error
we have another question and I think
this is the last one
uh could you instead train an auto
encoder and then do differential in the
embedding space may be constrained the
embedding spaces to a unit sphere might
be similar yeah I think this is uh
similar to an earlier question and again
yes you can definitely do that which
works better in practice I think it
still depends on the
um exact setting I think in our panotic
application segmentation application we
haven't seen another paper that's using
embedding space and make it work as well
as the the bit diffusion of the
diffusion model based on the analog bits
and I think is is simpler so that I
prefer simpler things
i i find I found it very intuitive by
the way uh I really like uh go to
research questions I think this is all
uh questions thanks a lot for accepting
uh to speak I really enjoyed yourself
thank you for having me yeah great see
ya
bye take care
so
um with this talk uh our kickoff Events
first day has ended we are going to have
two more days 14th and 17th on 14th we
have amazing talks from people from
hanging face Google brain and more so
please chime in tomorrow same time at 4
pm Jets and not to miss this live stream
take care
thank you